(gentle music)
- [Narrator] Do you
ever feel like sometimes
nothing seems to be going
right and then your one friend
who is super into astrology explains
that mercury is in retrograde?
The first thing we need to clear up,
is that mercury is not in retrograde,
mercury is just retrograde.
This is the astronomical phenomenon
when a planet appears
to be moving backwards
reversing its orbit from our
point of view here on earth.
It's actually an optical illusion.
You see, planets orbit the
sun at different speeds
and retrograde occurs generally
as a faster moving planet catches up with
and then passes a slower moving planet.
Other planets retrograde
too but because mercury
is the fastest planet in the solar system,
it retrogrades more frequently
about three to four times a year
and lasts for about two to three weeks.
Ancient Romans and Greeks personified
the planet mercury as the messenger deity.
Similarly in astrology, mercury
rules over communication.
It also governs analytical thinking,
expression of ideas, and the
processing of information.
So, in astrology when mercury retrogrades,
all those things get kind of scrambled.
Hence why some people feel utter
and total chaos during this period.
Different mercury retrogrades can have
different effects on us depending
on which sign it's moving through
and they can take on more of
the qualities of that sign.
For instance, the sign Cancer
is associated with home
and family as well as emotional intensity.
A mercury retrograding through Cancer
could have us focus on
aspects of our family
and home life and get deeper in touch
with our emotional state.
In 2018, all mercury retrogrades
will pass through fire signs,
Aries, Leo, and Sagittarius.
Therefore, we may be more willing
than normal to engage
in conflict over things
we're passionate about because
that's what fire signs do.
While there is generally
a negative connotation
surrounding retrograde periods,
there are also ways to
interpret mercury retrograde
that are more positive.
Since things will feel a
little crazy during retrograde,
it can be a good opportunity
to do some internal reflecting
rather than making impulsive decisions.
This can give you a chance to reassess
your desires and purpose.
So, now you know everything you need
to know about mercury retrograde.
Have fun using it as an excuse
for all of your problems.
Damn you mercury, damn you!
(gentle music)
- Hey, Unsolve is on a new
channel and now your part.
- Subscribe here.
- That was my part.